[Music]
and honor at Antonio's farm and I've
been farming here for ever since 2012
I have good years and bad years but this
year is look like it's going to be a
better year than last year so I'm
[Music]
happy well I have here
raspberries
corn and strawberries
then
some blueberries but the blueberry
plants were small so they probably take
another three years to be able to
harvest some and some sweet corn is
coming and peppers tomatoes becoming
some and that's about it but what I
really interest is in berries I'm a
berry
guy
well because this what I've been growing
for the
last six
years you know raspberries and
strawberries and now I'm trying
blueberries but kind of difficult to
grow because I never grown before so I
don't know what the and puts to put it
on but I'm leing little by little well
my great grandfather was agriculture my
grandpa then my dad and now myself so
we've been in generation in agriculture
for a
while we from Mexico you know we were
farming over there a long time and then
year 2000 uh
no
1972 I came over here when I was 18
years old and then I started working in
ores grown pears then I work for 28
years around here around here in the
and then two year 2000 I quit working in
or and then I started growing my own
bches then little by little I just
became to be a produce more and more and
now I I produce around 4
acres and that's how yeah 4
acres and that's how I started so I'm in
this business ever
since 2006 I was I started over there in
Sans Valley then I farm over there
for about 5 years then I mve over
here
2012 then I've been here ever
since yeah I've been putting some food
liers you know horse food liers in there
and messed it up with the soil and the
soil is looking great now so and then un
organic so I don't use
any chemical fertilizers or pesticides
whatsoever so I just do fertilizer I me
uh uh what do you call it
[Music]
those manur yeah I SC those in the fall
so that way if you be any problems the
so you clean them out so and then that's
how I do it I have some problems with
the bugs you know they sometimes they
eat 25% but then I get the 75% myself
and that's how it's been working but I
learn that if you keep a healthy plants
then the bags leave him
alone strawberries you know I just I
work for somebody before I start growing
it this is back in the year
2000 I was working for this guy I don't
remember his name but he was in the
Apple gate
area so he was a strawberry growing so I
work for him for three different seasons
then I learned some then year year 26 I
started growing my own and I've been
ruing making mistakes and there and I've
been uh growing St ever
since well no I buy the plants
first then after that then then the
starts I just transplanted every year
then when they get four or five years
old then I get new
ones I order some more new plants and
planting and do another four years and
then rotate
it that's it so this is my second year
and different brighty than for The Last
5 Years because this is no brighty and
seems to me it's working really well
because you can see the size of the ber
is pretty good size and this bright is
everywhere so
once it's adult they just keep it
producing all the way to October and you
have upic well where do you sell your
products I sell my products at the
farmers
grow yeah Farmers
Market three days a week
iand Co-op and shopping cart but I
haven't done that for the last two years
because we had a bad years not not
enough water so I hoping I get back
again in a year or two but I usually do
you pick but this year I don't think I'm
be going to be able because I don't have
enough so some guy calling me that he
wanted 20,000 lb
no I don't even answer him because shoot
no I don't have that me I don't know
where he was from but he left me a
message he he was interested in buy
strawberries he go he wanted 20,000
lb way too much fun my wife my kids they
helped me doing Harvest but the rest I
do
myself you know planting and weeding and
all that irrig I do myself because I
have it tractor and I have good
implements I can take
care and I can do that myself s Valley I
was farming over there back and I I
started over there 2006 and work all the
way
to
2010 but I was not enough water in there
I was pretty R so I was irrigating three
pounds you know so we get it a good good
heavy rainy year then we sto out water
but when I was a light year
raining so then it was same problem we
last two
years so then I move over here and I was
plenty water for the
next four years I think yeah and then
last year in the year before we we start
having the same problem not an hour but
this year it look like it's is going to
be enough enough water I just last all
my strawberries that I had before
because they they die and some of got
disease because being so right not an
hour and early spring and lay
fall that
will these all new plants that that I
planted
in this planting in
uh last June so I just plant this little
area here to get new plants and then the
rest I grab the plants for here and
Transplant them over there and the other
fields right over there so you can see
this B 12 rows in there and I have
another area I can put some more later
whenever I get enough
plants and up above are the raspberry
and then yeah then I have raspberries
over there The Raspberries got a little
hurt too you can see the area in the m
and how the ton and jell they're dying
too because of that but they're going to
come back once I keep them water enough
for now on they getting new new starts
coming we I grow some
masac my wife make a toras tamales you
know so this year I did it that because
I I was have extra L because you know
takes a little a whole year to fill it
up with the strawberries but usually
when I grow most is strawberries and
raspberries but this year you know I
didn't had enough plants for the whole
field so I grow a little corn here and
there just to keep everything
F and peppers too peppers I have some
peppers that I grow
for people you know and sometimes I make
a salsa for my myself for the
winter yeah so you know we've been
living off the farm my family and I so I
don't hire people cuz this is a family
farm and my my children don't want to be
a farmer they they think it's too much
work so they don't want to be getting a
stu like me working all the time is lot
of work sometimes it's not enough money
you know so but I do because I like it
and I enjoy eat what I
grow and if something be coming later
hard time to get it food then I can grow
my own so I'm not afraid of that cuz I
can grow
food so probably never happen but I'm
prepared oh that's right I'm not make it
a lot of money but enough just to
survive sometimes I got to borrow some
money for my friends not a lot because I
never want to get involved with the
banks because then in a bad year I know
I can lose my business so it's really
hard for me but I'm happy that I still
UNS survive that's the way yeah that's
the way yeah so and I'm making a lot of
money but sometimes I just make enough
to survive then sometimes when the in
the winter time then I work for somebody
else doing pruning so I can make it
money for to eat in that time so I'm not
dependent all by the farm so I do a lot
of
pruning fruit trees because
I after I harvest the corn till it end
and prepareing for for the garlet
because the garlet I plant them in
October and November
I put some in in October CLE teres
because it's four teres so I do four two
and then November I do the other
two then that way I can have a little
Oly garet for
them there's a three-year-old plants but
for the last two years they didn't grow
any because I didn't put enough water I
was just keeping
alive and and I'm
happy I did because I was using drip
just to make him survive but now it's
pling water so I've been giving him
enough so you can see I have no grown
sometimes it's a 10 in long already so
I'm happy they're
coming
see then these blueberries for their
down one brighty Orly is calling
chanders and for here up is another
seven row this call it aoras and they
coming in a later like in September
October so I I have different varies
they grow
different time so that way I can have a
little long season because if I get a
whole bunch all in once it's no no work
for me because I sell so much in each
market so I like have a little bit but
long
process and then over here I plant last
year seven chore RS at blackberry tnet
and they like this ground boy they they
doing really good look at they already
have a little fruit so Tas because those
who grow great and I I like
that
this is my raspberry patch and you can
see all those RADS in there last year
they were really solid road but I lost
all those plants because for the Run
being so right no water last year so and
then you can see the rest of the plants
and there some are dying but there's
going to be new stars coming
up always I always do so all these roads
they come not going to replant it in a
fall that way they can get it gone yeah
I want to get some more plants after of
this to and then fill it
up that way see see how next year it
will
be here so it turn like a campus so I
put it all the way around and look at
the difference in the plants they look
beautiful they like
that and the fruga little l
and these are organic 100% I never use
no chemical feres or
pesticides good
stuff good and
tasty that's why I like to be a farmer
because nothing tastes better than from
the bind to your
mouth
[Music]